Jacob starts off this hour in Washington
DC hi Jacob welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show how you doing Dave better than I
deserve sir how about you I'm doing good
I just had a quick question for you so I
am just graduated from college this past
May and I have about only eleven four
thousand dollars in student loans good a
family member has gifted me over the
years of stock that accumulates up to
about eighteen to twenty thousand just
depending on the stock price my question
for you is should I use that and go
ahead and knock out my student debt or
save it I'm getting married next spring
and I could save it and then eventually
use that as a down payment on a house
within a year or two of being married
okay well we teach people the data
points that we have learned and that is
the shortest distance between where you
are and becoming wealthy is to become
and stay debt-free
I would never borrow money on a student
loan to buy stock and in a sense I know
that isn't what happened but in a sense
it's the same thing because every day
that you don't use this stock to pay off
the student loan it's mathematically as
if you borrowed money on the student
loan to buy stock does that make sense
yeah I can kind of see your point there
yeah and so what do you make a year so
I'm actually in the transition of
getting a new job potentially um to
where my pay would be right short of 40
a year cool all right and so what I
would tell you to do is to become
debt-free and use the balance of that
money to build your emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses and then
at that point if you wanted to not start
investing yet and instead start piling
up money for the wedding the marriage
and the down payment on the house and
spend the next year doing that very
aggressively with a budget where you're
living on a plan or their money's being
very intentional then that's going to be
okay
now if you do not follow through if you
do not live on a plan if you do not live
on a budget and make your money behave
if you do not later start investing if
you don't save some money instead you
spend all your money goofing off over
the next year and you come into this
marriage completely broke with no down
payment for a house and now your wedding
is a new debt and all of those kinds of
things then my advice was bad but my
advice presupposes that you're going to
be wise and intentional with money from
this day forward yes sir I've been using
every dollar for about four months now
hey there you go
that's exactly what I'm talking about
perfect yeah so you're making your money
behave already isn't it it's very
enlightening it shows you what what's
happening with your life doesn't it yes
it does yeah very cool yes I would bar I
would cash in the stock and finish up
through baby steps right that's your
only debt is the student loan debt yes
they're perfect no card debt no card and
as far as I understand I'm coming out of
school with that free as well amazing
okay well if she's your fiancee then you
need to have deeper discussions about
that to be very sure so that everyone
knows where everyone is and by the way
you can tell her you have a fully funded
emergency fund and you're debt-free and
now then the person who gave you this
gift the grandfather the uncle or the
aunt or whoever it was that gave you the
stock gift all those years ago
you have honored them by using it wisely
to build wealth the fastest does that
make sense yes there get after it man
you're on the right track